joining us here kinda enough to call in
on short notice is our buddy who's been
covering Houston sports since the mid
70s from the Houston Chronicle John
McLane how are you today John
I'm doing great rich how are you I'm
doing fine right here in the capitol one
guest line in the middle of our news
update I appreciate you providing this
information where did this come from
John why did this happen
DeAndre Hopkins wants a new contract
he's got three years left on his
contract they were not going to redo a
deal with three years left even though
Bill O'Brien is the general manager and
he has control of everything now the
most they've ever done was Andre Johnson
and JJ Watt at two years left and it's
not going to do it and so it's a good
year for receivers this becomes their
number one priority considering they
have Kenny Stills will fuller than last
year their contract and then fuller
can't stay healthy this becomes a big
priority and free agency and the draft
so you're saying they were receiving
information from DeAndre Hopkins or his
camp that he might not show up this year
with three years left on his deal so why
not go ahead and and and deal him now is
that I know they're worried about that
but I know he wants a new contract when
he signed it he got 49 million
guaranteed most in NFL history fair
receiver he's gonna make 12 and a half
million this year thirteen and a half
next year and that doesn't put him among
the league leaders he's coming off
another first-team all-pro selection
another Pro Bowl and deshaun Watson of
course he's their second bit second most
important offensive player to deshaun
Watson and that takes a huge chunk out
of this offense and I don't know how
they're gonna replace it that's my gosh
John that's the question I have for you
here is that how does this get sold to
the rest of the team and and deshaun
Watson I mean isn't this one of the most
popular players that's in that in that
locker room oh yeah but they don't have
to sell it you know Bill O'Brien in
charge just like on that Laremy Tunsil
Kenny Stills deal the fans went crazy
media went crazy as you can imagine here
right now fans and meteor going crazy
and but you know you're the only person
he's got to sell it to is the owner Cal
McNair and obviously he signed off on it
so
what do you think this means for for the
offense John I mean I guess then I'll
ask this question what this deal have
gotten done if Bill O'Brien wasn't the
the general the the general manager
redone to deal with three years left
absolutely not they would not do that
set that kind of president for any
player and they wouldn't have done it
under Brian Gaynor Rick Smith or Charlie
Cassady because that's just not the way
they've operated and not many team to do
with that much time left
it's obvious O'Brien likes David Johnson
he and he had a great second year he's
at injury issues he's a backup to Kenyan
break it's a great deal for Kyle Murray
and Kliff Kingsbury think about how
happy Kyler Murray ought to be right now
prepared did Shaun Watson John
appreciate the time I know you got your
time was short here and you're you're on
the case for some other news going on
appreciate it thanks thank you very much
for it you got it thanks John